[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin schönen freitagabend ihnen
allen christian autos wieder bei mir für
den sport sehr gerne genannt und
gemeinsam blicken wir jetzt auf unseren
themen überblick
empörung nach raketenangriff auf kiew
den russischen beschuss während des
besuchs von un-chef guten schnitt berlin
menschenverachtend
kritik an kürzerer isolations zeit für
corona infizierte die geplante fünf tage
frist stößt auf widerstand
patientenschützer fordern eine freitext
uns pflicht
und tiefer fall einer tennis ikone boris
becker muss ins gefängnis ein londoner
gericht verurteilt ihn wegen
insolvenzverschleppung zu zweieinhalb
jahren haft
[Musik]
ukrainische präsident selent ski hat
sich bei den usa für die geplanten
militär und wirtschaftshilfen in höhe
von 33 milliarden dollar bedankt und den
russischen raketenangriff auf kiew
während des besuches des
un-generalsekretärs gestern scharf
verurteilt ebenso die bundesregierung an
den kriegsfronten im osten und süden
wird weiter hart und erbittert gekämpft
die geschehnisse am kriegstag 65 fasst
jürgen kehl zusammen
kiew am mittag in dieses appartement
haus war eine der raketen eingeschlagen
in den trümmern finden die retter eine
tote frau eine unserer journalistinnen
sagt radio free europe ein
amerikanischer sender das russische
verteidigungsministerium erklärt man
habe in kiew nur militärische ziele
zerstört bewohner berichten von fünf
einschlägen
es ist so schwer die töten so viele
menschen die lassen niemanden leben
zurück entschuldigung ich kann nicht
mehr
politisch brisant zum zeitpunkt der
attacke der ersten seit knapp zwei
wochen war der oberste uno repräsentant
zu gesprächen mit der ukrainischen
regierung in der stadt
hier ist heilig für ukraine und russen
das ist nicht wichtig ob der
un-generalsekretär hier ist oder nicht
das ist eine so schöne stadt die so
wichtig ist für die geschichte und die
kultur dass die angegriffen wird das
schockiert mich natürlich
das ist ein symbolischer moment der
un-generalsekretär ist in kiew mit der
zerstörung unserer häuser mit den
beschuss zeigt den putin genau dann den
mittelfinger
dione und die ganze welt blicken seit
wochen auf das stahlwerk in mariupol
noch immer verschanzen sich dort
ukrainische kämpfern zahlreiche
zivilisten
aufnahmen des chinesischen fernsehens
zeigen einen konvoi der sich
möglicherweise für eine evakuierung
bereit hält in der nieder gewalzten
stadt sind nur noch wenige bewohner
geblieben zeugen und fassbarer gewalt
das ist wie das ende der welt sagt diese
frau so ähnlich ist das hier sie
berichtet von hunger schreienden kindern
und raketen grafen direkt hinter ihrem
haus
russland zeigt heute panzer und
artillerie im angriff die feindliche
logistik sei weiter eines der
bevorzugten ziele heißt es auch die
ukraine meldet erfolge ein
munitionslager auf russisch
kontrolliertem gebiet soll zerstört
worden sein von einer komplexen lage
sprach der uno-generalsekretär bei
seinem abschied heißt im klartext die
gewalt wird weitergehen
vom osten her schiebt sich die
frontlinie langsam ins land und immer
mehr menschen müssen damit rechnen unter
beschuss zu geraten auch in po cross
einer bergbau und industrie statt mit
früher einmal 65.000 einwohnern von dort
berichtet unser reporter dara
hassanzadeh
prof die letzte stadt vor der front noch
sind die kriegsschäden hier
vergleichsweise gering wir treffen
nikolai ist für die sicherheit in der
stadt fahren freundlich
bei luftangriffen einschlägen von
mörsern oder explosionen schicken wir
die leute in die keller die wir
vorbereitet haben
keller werden zu bunkern vorräte an
essen und medikamenten für die menschen
sind angelegt selbst brunnen für wasser
haben sie gebohrt
die menschen hier leben mit der hoffnung
dass der krieg ihre stadt verschonen
wird sie leben mit der angst dass die
russische armee die letzten wenigen
kilometer erobern wird dass sie
eingekesselt werden und ihre stadt
zerstört wird essensausgabe ohne hilfe
würden die menschen hier hungern eine
tüte sie muss für zwei tage reichen
wir kaufen nur brot selbst im moment
gibt es kaum zucker auch kein mehl den
rest tauschen wir untereinander
nur wer bei der stadt angestellt ist
verdient noch geld alle anderen müssen
versorgt werden
wir beamte können jetzt nicht gehen es
ist unmöglich wie würden wir uns dann
fühlen wie ein verräter nein das ist
nicht unsere welt
noch 20.000 menschen leben in prof und
sie wissen am horizont dort ist der
krieg
moskaus drohungen haben in den
vergangenen tagen nicht nachgelassen
gleichzeitig kündigt wladimir putin an
im herbst am gipfel der wichtigsten
industrie- und schwellenländer g-20
teilnehmen zu wollen sowieso soll in
moskau alles so laufen wie immer auch
der neunte mai der tag des sieges über
nazi deutschland der tag wird mit viel
militär gefeiert die proben dazu laufen
und christian senn hat sie gesehen wenn
panzer und raketenwerfer im frühjahr
durch moskaus innenstadt rollen weiß
jeder hier bald ist wieder neunter mal
probe gestern abend während in der
ukraine die militärische
spezialoperation läuft wie der krieg
hier offiziell bezeichnet wird
öffentlich kritisieren was gerade in der
ukraine passiert traut sich hier niemand
ich will das nicht kommentieren
ist nur fürs deutsche fernsehen
ohne kamera werde ich antworten
ich mag unseren präsidenten sehr denn er
beschützt uns ich möchte niemanden
kränken aber putin ist ein präsident für
die welt ich liebe ihn
jedes jahr wird mit der parade auf dem
roten platz an das ende des zweiten
weltkriegs erinnert dieses mal mit
weniger soldaten und 11.000 und weniger
technik als im letzten jahr die
feierlichkeiten zum sieg über nazi
deutschland erscheinen in diesem jahr in
einem besonderen licht der kreml spricht
von bedeutenden verlusten bei der
militäroperationen in der ukraine und
präsident putin will hier am 9
militärische erfolge präsentieren am
alten arbeit im touristenviertel werden
t shirts mit dem großen z verkauft
merchandising für die militär operation
und von der iss grüßen die russischen
kosmonauten zum neunten mal mit der
sowjetischen sieges flagge
es gibt wieder ein ganz frisches
zdf-politbarometer matthias fornoff ist
bei uns mit sehr vielen zahlen matthias
gestern hat der bundestag mit großer
mehrheit für die lieferung auch schwerer
waffen an die ukrainischen wie denken
die bürger darüber ja guten abend
erstmal das hatte einen deutlichen
meinungsumschwung gegeben eine mehrheit
von 56 prozent ist jetzt dafür dass
deutschland auch schwere waffen an die
ukraine liefert im märz sah das noch
ganz anders aus 63 prozent lehnten das
ab wie die bundesregierung die ukraine
insgesamt unterstützt findet die hälfte
der befragten gerade richtig und fast
jeder dritte sagt es ist noch zu wenig
und wie machen politikerinnen und
politiker ihre sache in der ukraine
krise kanzler scholz stürzt da auf 49
prozent zustimmung ab im märz waren es
noch 72 prozent zwei drittel sagen
wirtschaftsminister habeck macht einen
guten job sogar 70 prozent attestieren
dass außenministerin berbalk die grünen
als partei legen denn auch zu im
politbarometer matthias nächsten sonntag
8 mai da gibt es landtagswahlen in
schleswig holstein wie sieht es da aus
der bundes- und landestrend die gehen
nicht immer in die gleiche richtung das
sehen wir hier denn wenn am sonntag
gewählt würde in schleswig holstein wäre
die cdu mit 38 prozent sehr klar vorn
spd 19 grüne 17 fdp 7 afd 6 linke 3 und
südschleswigscher wählerverband 5
prozent das jamaika bündnis in kiel ist
im grunde beliebt es könnte aber auch
für ein zweierbündnis reichen ein grund
für die stärke der cdu ist sicher ihr
spitzenkandidat denn 66 prozent wollen
daniel günther als ministerpräsidenten
behalten die herausforderer weit
abgeschlagen da ist jedenfalls im moment
keine wechselstimmung festzustellen ja
dann vielen dank matthias fornoff war ja
nur ein kleiner vorgeschmack
das ausführliche politbarometer das gibt
es wie immer im heute-journal ab 22 uhr
und schon jetzt finden sie alle zahlen
in unserer zdf heute app auch zur
wirtschaftslage und der allgemeinen
politischen stimmung im land
die abhängigkeit von russischer energie
gilt nicht nur für importe sondern auch
für einige anlagen in deutschland die
mehrheitlich in besitz eines russischen
staatsunternehmens sind darum will die
bundesregierung der gesetzesnovelle die
möglichkeit bekommen zur not auch
unternehmen enteignen zu können bernd
benthin mit den einzelheiten die pck
raffinerie im brandenburgischen schwedt
versorgt große teile deutschlands mit
kraftstoffen und gehört zum größten teil
dem russischen rosneft-konzern für die
neue deutsche energiepolitik ein
unhaltbarer zustand erklärt der
wirtschaftsminister auf twitter trotz
bislang russische staatskonzern und die
haben natürlich gar keine interessen
daran dass sie nicht russisches öl
raffinieren also wenn ich da anrufe und
sagt hallo was heute eigentlich tun um
wunder kann ich von russischem öl zu
werden dann werden die den hörer gar
nicht ab und sagen hey was willst du
eigentlich von uns das ist genau unser
geschäftsmodell habeck seit heute in
corona isolation hofft dass er bald
härter gegen rosneft vorgehen kann dafür
wollen die ampel parteien das energie
sicherungs gesetz verschärfen dann
sollen auch enteignungen möglich sein
jeder der kritische infrastruktur in
deutschland gegen die deutschen und
europäischen interessen missbraucht der
kann nicht weiter eigentümer dieser
kritischen infrastruktur sein meine
damen und herren auch die eigentümer von
gasspeichern sollen als letztes mittel
enteignet werden können einige dieser
russischen anlagen in deutschland stehen
schon jetzt unter treuhandverwaltung die
union signalisiert zustimmung zum neuen
gesetz die linke fordert man solle noch
weiter gehen wir als linke sagen
kritische infrastruktur wird dauerhaft
in die öffentliche hand und das ist
glaube ich die richtige und wichtige
forderung in die st dort seien im mai so
jedenfalls der ampel plan soll das neue
gesetz beschlossen sein
jetzt nach afghanistan bei einer
schweren explosion in der hauptstadt
kabul sollen laut innenministerium
mindestens zehn menschen getötet worden
sein die bombe sei während des gebets in
einer moschee detoniert das land wird
seit wochen von anschlägen erschüttert
erst gestern wurden in masar i scharif
neun menschen durch explosionen in den
tod gerissen zu der tat bekannt hat sich
ein ableger des islamischen staates
der chef der europäischen
grenzschutzagentur frontex fabrice adde
jerry ist zurückgetreten hintergrund
sind so genannte push becks also die
illegale teils gewaltsame zurückweisung
von migranten im fokus der vorwürfe auch
immer wieder der griechische grenzschutz
berichten zufolge sollen führungskräfte
von frontex verstöße absichtlich
vertuscht haben frontex einheiten
unterstützen eu staaten an ihren
außengrenzen
zu corona da zeichnen sich weitere
lockerungen in deutschland ab wer
infiziert ist soll sich nur noch fünf
tage isolieren und nicht mehr wie bisher
in den meisten bundesländern zehn tage
darauf haben sich bund und länder
grundsätzlich geeinigt strittig ist
allerdings noch ob am ende ein test
freiwillig oder verpflichtend sein soll
britta spiekermann
lauterbach lockert bund und länder sind
sich einig und planen die
vorgeschriebene isolation für corona
infizierte von jetzt zehn auf fünf tage
zu verkürzen
ich persönlich glaube dass am ende rund
fünf tagen das ja sehr kurze zeit eine
selbsttötung zumindest eine selbsttötung
dringend empfohlen sein müsste weil wir
wissen dass viele nach dem fünften tag
noch positiv sind und die würden dann ja
doch noch andere anstecken daher ist
eine
freisetzung auch für diejenigen die
keine symptome mehr sinnvoll ein test
nach fünf tagen wird also vom minister
dringend empfohlen eine pflicht gibt es
nicht der virologe martin stürmer hält
das für nicht ausreichend zudem werde
die omikron variante verharmlost wenn
man aber anspruch hat infektion zu
vermeiden denn kann man nicht einfach am
mikro so behandeln infektionen einfach
laufen lassen wir haben immer noch
ungeklärte situation was longo wird
angeht ärztevertreter hingegen
unterstützen lockerungen sie fordern
schon länger mehr eigenverantwortung
isolationen könnten angesichts hoher
infektionszahlen ohnehin kaum
kontrolliert werden zum einen haben wir
ja eine extrem hohe dunkelziffer das
heißt es ist ja eine scheinsicherheit zu
meinen mit diesen isolations pflichten
würde man relevant eingriff auf
inspektions geschehen nehmen und die
unterm strich doch sehr milden verlauf
von omikron rechtfertigen dass auch für
medizinisches personal soll nach ende
der fünftägigen isolation ein test
allerdings verpflichtend sein die neuen
empfehlungen wird das
robert-koch-institut kommende woche
veröffentlichen die umsetzung ist dann
ländersache
sie haben es mitbekommen krone bedingt
viel das münchner oktoberfest ja zwei
jahre hintereinander aus aber dieses
jahr wird wieder ozapft entschied jetzt
oberbürgermeister reiter statt einer
kleinen wiesen wie zurzeit gibt es ab
mitte september wieder die große wiesen
ganz ohne auflagen münchen ist die
freude groß und sechs millionen besucher
lockte das größte volksfest der welt vor
der pandemie an
boris becker erfolgreichste
tennisspieler der deutschen geschichte
hat eine ganze generation begeistert
inspiriert und auch zum tennisspielen
gebracht jetzt ist die ikone zu
zweieinhalb jahren haft verurteilt
worden wegen insolvenzverschleppung
das gericht in england sprach ihn in
vier von 24 anklagepunkten schuldig nach
dem ersten wimbledonsieg 1985 kamen
millionen durch preisgeld und werbung
und gingen schnell verloren durch seinen
lebensstil ein unglückliches händchen
bei geschäften und teuren scheidungen
yasin herrlein aus london
es war genau 15 uhr 45 ortszeit als die
richterin das graf max verkündete zwei
jahre sechs monate haft davon maximal
zwölf monate auf bewährung am vormittag
bei der ankunft am gericht mit seiner
freundin war da vielleicht noch ein
hauch von zuversicht in beckers gesicht
heute nachmittag dann konnte er das
gerichtsgebäude nicht mehr durch den
haupteingang verlassen wie konnte es
dazu kommen für das tennis wunderkind
bis heute ist becker der jüngste
wimbledon sieger seither gehört er zu
den ikonen des deutschen sports er
machte millionen mit seinem tennis und
als werbefigur geld kam rein und gingen
noch schneller ein luxuriöser lebensstil
teure scheidung unterhalt für die
tochter aus der besenkammer-affäre kein
glück als unternehmer
2017 wird becker für bankrott erklärt
geschätzt 60 millionen euro schulden
doch becker kooperiert nicht ausreichend
im insolvenzverfahren das kommt zum
prozess sein anwalt argumentiert seine
berater seien schuld gewesen becker sei
zu jung zu berühmt geworden schon immer
gefordert im umgang mit geld doch
ungewissheit und unfähigkeit schützen
nicht vor strafe so brillant becker auf
dem platz war so tiefen und sein fall am
17 juli 1985 geht er mit dem dritten
triumph in die geschichtsbücher ein fast
vier jahrzehnte später ist es wieder
london diesmal geht es ins gefängnis
eine berufung ist möglich die aussicht
auf erfolg eher zweifelhaft wortlos und
sichtlich geschockt verließen freundin
lilian und so nur das gerichtsgebäude
becker selbst wurde in einem
gefängniswagen weg gebracht
ein schwerer tag für bäckerfamilie und
bäcker freunde aber auch für die vielen
becker fans christina aber sportlich
bleibt er ein ganz ganz großer ist
unbestritten wir machen jetzt einen
schnitt zum fußball hin es geht um den
neuen trainer von österreichs nationalen
und er kommt aus deutschland ralf
rangnick empfindet es als eine ehre
neuer teamchef der österreicher zu
werden zunächst für zwei jahre
erste herausforderung bereits am dritten
juni nations league auswärts in kroatien
genug erfahrung hat er ja ein paar
monate übergangstrainer bei manchester
united liegen hinter ihm ein schwieriges
starensemble um cristiano ronaldo hat er
gekauft nun reizt die neue aufgabe als
nationaltrainer mit großer vorfreude
erfüllt mich insbesondere die aussicht
mit einer jungen erfolgshungrigen
mannschaft die europameisterschaft in
deutschland zu bestreiten österreich
erfahren ist rangnick nach acht jahren
als sportdirektor in salzburg
er löst franco foda ab der die
wm-qualifikation verpasste trotz des
frühen ausscheidens in der champions
league soll rang nicht beratend tätig
bleiben für manchester hoffentlich muss
er in seinem neuen job weniger oft den
kopf schütteln
das deutsche finalduell frankfurt gegen
leipzig ist in der europa league
weiterhin gut möglich r b setzte sich im
halbfinal hinspiel gegen die glasgow
rangers mit 1 0 durch wobei an re linie
erst in der 85 minute den siegtreffer
erzielte und
großer jubel auch bei der eintracht die
im londoner hexenkessel von west ham
united flott los legte zwischendurch
etwas bangen musste und letztlich doch
mit 2 1 gewann die 3000 mitgereisten
frankfurter fans sorgten fast schon für
finalstimmung im londoner olympiastadion
die mannschaft schien dadurch beflügelt
bereits nach 49 sekunden die führung für
die eintracht durch drauf west ham nun
wachgerüttelt noch in der ersten
halbzeit antonio mit dem ausgleich nach
dem seitenwechsel die gäste aus
frankfurt wieder stärker kanada und das
erlösende 2 1 für frankfurt in der
nachspielzeit noch eine spektakuläre
szene fallrückzieher bauen und frankfurt
im glück das gehört doch dazu das muss
man sich dann noch arbeiten von daher
war es eine sehr gute vorstellung von
uns schon mit einem unentschieden
nächste woche könnte der traum vom
endspiel in sevilla war wem
das wäre am 18 mal gucken
so das wochenendwetter zweigeteilt im
norden kühler und sonniger im süden viel
wechselhafter mehr gleich von katja
horneffer das heute journal heute um 22
uhr mit bettina schausten so viel von
uns vielen dank schön start ins
wochenende morgen hier für sie barbara
halbe
[Musik]
guten abend heute war das wetter ja noch
vergleichsweise ruhig für viele schien
auch die sonne und es gab meist nur hohe
und harmlose wolkenfelder das wird sich
jetzt aber ändern denn hier von
frankreich kommen dichtere wolken heran
mit schauern und gewittern und die
beschäftigen uns schon heute abend und
auch in der nacht im westen und dem
südwesten deutschlands gibt es also
schauer und gewitter nordöstlich der
elbe dagegen bleibt ist klar und die
temperaturen sinken auf 10 bis 2 grad
und steigen morgen hier im osten auf 18
bis 20 grad meist liegen die werte bei
13 bis 17 grad kühler ist es dagegen
hier an der nordseeküste und auch am
alpenrand mit elf grad allerdings diese
elf grad ganz unterschiedlichen gründen
geschuldet denn an der nordseeküste
liegt das an dem wind aus nordwestlichen
richtungen am alpenrand dagegen gehen
diese 11 grad zurück auf die kräftigen
wolken wie es da gibt auch kräftige
schauer und gewitter da werden sie die
sonne kaum zu gesicht bekommen schauer
und gewitter beschäftigen vor allen
dingen die südhälfte deutschlands im
norden ist es freundlicher da wechseln
sonne und wolken miteinander ab und
diese regenschauer und gewitter von
morgen ziehen dann am sonntag weiter
richtung südosten dann kann sich am
oberrhein an der mosel auch mal wieder
die sonne zeigen schönes wochenende